- Hello there, I'm Gav.
- I'm Dan.
- We're The Slow Mo Guys.
Dan, what would you say
is the most interesting natural disaster?
- I'm quite impressed by
things like tornadoes.
- Tornadoes, good.
- They're pretty cool.
- I quite like wildlife.
- Should we sort of combine the two?
- Melting pot.
The fire tornado is
actually, surprisingly,
a naturally-occurring event.
Pretty rare.
- Pretty awesome.
- Pretty awesome, so
we're gonna recreate it
with about 12 box fans in
a circle and some fire.
- Okay, so we've got about half an inch
of kerosene in there.
Just gonna light it, step
back, and let it build up
and then we'll just
turn the fans on, okay?
- All right, I'm ready on Phantom.
- Here we go.
- Yeah, that's lit.
- Okay, I'll just let it build up.
- Go for it.
- Yep.
- Oh sweet.
That's like 10 foot there.
- [Dan] Oh that's awesome, look at that.
- [Gavin] That's class.
- [Dan] That's cool.
- That got really high.
- [Dan] Yeah.
- [Gavin] Can feel the heat.
- [Dan] Yeah, I still.
If it wasn't hot enough.
- Look at that.
- [Dan] It's literally a perfect spiral.
Look at that.
That's wicked.
- Well Dan, I'm not bein'
funny, that looked phenomenal.
- Yeah, looks amazing doesn't it?
- I'm always wafflin' on
about how liquids and flame looks good.
Spinning flame, even better.
I think from now on, all
flames should be spinning.
- Yeah, it looked so good,
I just wanted to it eat it.
- It did look good enough to eat.
- It looked so smooth.
- I've never wanted
to eat fire before.
- Yeah, looked so nice.
- It was golden.
Did you get singed?
- Actually, for once, I
didn't lose any arm hair,
no eyebrows, no hair, nothing.
I was all right.
- We played it safe.
- Quite happy with that.
- Feel free to follow us
on Twitter, buy a shirt.
Thank you very much for watching.
- Yeah, see ya next time.